welcome to the voices in leadership
series on behalf of the Harvard th Chan
School of Public Health I would like to
welcome her studio audience
as well as the many viewers online who
are watching us live on the webcast the
website of the voices series and also
across the university of california we
are very honored to have with us today
janet napolitano president of the
university of california former
secretary of the US Department of
Homeland Security and former governor of
Arizona Janet Napolitano was named the
20th president of the University of
California in July 2013 she leads a
university system with 10 campuses five
medical centers three affiliated
national laboratories and a statewide
agriculture and natural resources
program president Paula tano earned her
Bachelor of Science degree from
accumulating in political science in
1979 from Santa Clara University were
among many other accomplishments she was
the university's first female
valedictorian in 1983 she earned a law
degree from the University of Virginia
School of Law and actually in 2010 she
was awarded the prestigious Thomas
Jefferson Foundation Medal which is the
highest external honor bestowed by the
University of Virginia her career as an
attorney paved her way for her role as
governor of Arizona and later as
Secretary of Homeland Security and I
actually had the great honor of meeting
her about ten years ago when she was
governor of Arizona and we were
launching in Mexico the national list
for genomic medicine and through an
initiative in Arizona they provide very
valuable assistance to to Mexico I was
then the Minister of Health there I'd
like to paraphrase several striking
comments that President Napolitano made
a few months ago about leadership
she said that leaders must have a term a
long term vision they must think vigor
and persuade other people that they want
to be part of
is something bigger they must also have
a sense of how to get it done and then
they must have the wisdom and patience
to step back and let others do it so
today we are going to partake of her
wisdom and her incredible experience her
wealth of experience in leadership roles
and it will be really fascinating to see
how president Napolitano abuse
leadership and how she distinguish it
from management this discussion will of
course draw on her own leadership
experience as governor secretary and now
as university president I'm very pleased
that Professor Robert Landon who's the
senior dean for policy translation and
leadership development and the richer
Elm Richard Menchel professor joins
today discussion as the model the
moderator so before I turn the session
over to Professor blendin please join me
in welcoming janet napolitano
to the voices in leadership series at
the Harvard th Chan School of Public
Health
júlio thank you very much this is a very
special series if you allow me just fer
I'm gonna to talk about this
it's an idea which came from many
students and it has to do with the fact
that most of us everyday watch people
who leave global national state
institutions they're huge they're
distant they're far away somehow we
believe that they take over these
institutions they have a vision about
how they're gonna change where the river
will go they're the outcome for it and
so many students ask the question about
if you take over one of these
institutions you play these roles how do
you think about where you go and what
you change and how I bring people in so
this series is actually not about what
we usually do public policy what issue
another it's about how people take on
institutions the reason for doing that
is that those of you in the audience and
those of you broader some day are going
to take on some of these roles and the
question is what would I do if I had
this role so that's how this is really
structured so usually we have a guest
and they have one successful role we
have an issue here I'm trying to do that
we have three very distinct unbelievably
successful roles so what we're going to
do is break the questions into a period
of being governor of Arizona and then
take some questions which have been
written in or passed around and then
we're going to go to Homeland Security
for those of you from other nations the
United States did not have apartment
like this until after 2001 and the
tragedy led the United States to put
together a huge range of agencies with
somewhat different cultures and mission
in one place and becoming cabinet
secretary of that also the agency has a
special role
with the president because this is the
phone you pick up when there is a crises
whether it's national disasters a
various sort or terrorist and so that
and thirdly what would have been more
than enough
she has become president of probably the
largest public university research wise
in the world who clearly the United
States and the best at absolutely the
reason why she became governor of
Arizona was so I'm going to start just
the the questions often trying to ask
what people might do if they're also
students first and you can't escape the
fact at what point in your life that you
decide you were going to go into
elective politics and there was again
I'm pretending I forgot my American
history but there were periods when
women didn't do it at the rate they did
and there you were entering elective
office Attorney General running for
governor how did you make that decision
and my one sort of amusing side is her
father was Dean of the University of
Mexico School of Medicine so I'm dying
to know how he felt about that career
choice well a little bit about how it
came about after I graduate from law
school I moved to Arizona to clerk for a
federal judge which is a common thing
that lawyers do if they can't decide
where they want to take the bar exam
which was my situation I decided to
remain in Arizona I practiced law with a
law firm for ten years was a partner
when President Clinton was elected he
was actually looking for women to fill
some non-traditional roles and one of
those non-traditional roles was being
the United States Attorney which is the
chief federal prosecutor for a
particular area and Arizona is one
federal region or district as they're
called so that's a presidential
appointment with
confirmation so I went through the
process and I had been serving as US
attorney for a little over four years I
was 39 by then I was 39 turning 40 and I
had thought a little bit about running
for office but not not too seriously but
the attorney generalship of Arizona was
going to be an open seat and I had this
moment where I said you know I don't
want to be in my older age in my rocking
chair saying woulda coulda shoulda done
something and that the worst thing that
would happen would be that I would lose
and I'd go back to my law practice and
have a very nice life and do a lot of
community oriented activities on the
side so from a risk analysis that was
that side but I called my dad he still
lived in Albuquerque New Mexico and I
told him dad I've got to resign as US
Attorney to run for attorney general and
there was a moment of silence on the
phone my family is by the way is not a
family of lawyers and politicians or
what have you there are scientists and
engineers and people like that so I was
kind of the odd one out in that respect
and there's a moment of silence I
imagine your kid calling you and telling
you this and and he said Janet I want to
understand you were partner in a law
firm making X then you took a job as US
attorney which paid half of X now you're
gonna make no money for nine months
while you campaign for a job that makes
about a third of X and he goes I don't
understand and I and I said I'm not
worried he said why not and so I said
because the trust fund you've had for me
my whole life that you have been you
know keeping from me so that I would go
to be he dependent and hardworking you
can now share it with me it's okay
that'll be alright so no worries so he
left huh anyway a couple days later I
get a check in the mail made out to
Janet 98 my campaign fund it was in the
amount of $5 and it was signed
Napolitano trust fund and then he wrote
on the ledger exhaustion of principal
and interest but it was really one of it
was a combination of things it was I
felt at that point I had more than
enough experience for the job very
interested in public service at a
certain point if you want to be in
public service you should consider
running for office yourself and it was
the right time in the right office and
it was by no means a sure thing that I
would win I'm a Democrat
I was running in Arizona not a state
well-known for electing Democrats wait
one minute before I asked about that
question and it was a tough campaign but
we did win and then three years later
the governorship was going to be an open
seat there's a strategy here and I ran
for governor and that was probably my
toughest campaign was to win as governor
and I had a primary at a four-way
primary when that finished the general
election up against a very tough
Republican congressman who was kind of
their designated guide to be the
governor and the race was not actually
decided - about five days after the
election fortunately when I ran for
re-election as governor we'd had a good
run as governor we'd done a lot of
things and we had a lot of things in the
queue that we wanted to get done
so my second race as governor was
declared the minute the polls closed so
let's deal with the decision-making
issues you're elected governor and you
want to have things that really happen
they're important how do you go about
doing that how do you decide the kinds
of people you were going to attract an
appoint how did you decide what your
agenda was going to be for that there
has to be some lessons learned the sort
of thinking ahead about you took over
you wanted it to be very different when
you left but it's a very hard
environment to get things done it is and
and I had a legislature that was
overwhelmingly Republican in both houses
and very very conservative Republican
not too many moderates left well I think
you do a couple of things from a
management perspective you you have to
figure out some key positions and fill
them with key people during the
transition period so that the minute you
are inaugurated you are ready to go
chief among those is your chief of staff
because I've always believed in a model
with a strong chief of staff you can
manage things differently that's the way
I choose to do it a strong chief of
staff and interoffice team and you pick
a couple things they have to be
obviously they have to have the talents
they have to be smart they have to be
willing to work long hours they have to
be able to get along and and work with
each other sometimes in a very stressful
atmosphere you learn about some people
that way during a campaign but you learn
about people that way in other roles as
well so you don't just pick from the
campaign team I had a bipartisan
transition team because in in the
politics and the place where I was I
couldn't just have Democrats I needed to
be working with Republicans and so I
co-chaired the transition team with a 1r
and one D so the the immediate team and
then you pick key members of the
administration for example the the
equivalent of that of the Health
Minister well public health is a big
issue for a governor and you want
someone
who is knowledgeable in the field who is
not you know learning from you know
elementary bases but has some experience
and someone you can trust to run that
institution well another key role for a
governor is the head of corrections
unfortunately in America I think we have
way too many people incarcerated prisons
are large complicated institutions and
you need a really good Corrections
director and that came to bear not too
long in my governorship when we had two
of our guards taken hostage at a
maximum-security prison and we actually
were in a hostage negotiation there for
almost two full weeks 24/7 and where
there was a high likelihood that we were
going to have fatalities so having a
good Corrections director with you at
that time absolutely key the head of
your department of revenue you know not
sexy but boy it's nuts and bolts tough
for a governor you know somebody's got
to run the tax system and then you need
to have someone experienced at the head
of Public Safety in our state the head
of education was actually an elected
position so was not one I control but
those were the key kind of cabinet roles
that every governor has to find the
right person for how did you find them
you find them a couple of ways word of
mouth is a big way there's something
called the National Governors
Association it has a staff that staff
knows people around the country they
know people who know people you talked
to people who have been governors who
have they work with how did they do it
so there it's all of that obviously
these are public service jobs they get
posted but the formal kind of process is
not nearly as important as
that informal one so let's talk about
the agenda yeah you even though it looks
like it's forever you take over and
governor you realize it's very time
limited agenda and you have to set some
set of priorities and strategies to try
to move things along how did you decide
what your priorities would be and
strategies for trying to move that
actually to happen in Arizona a couple
of ways one I was fortunate I'd serve as
the US Attorney in the Attorney General
I knew state government from the
Attorney General job and I knew kind of
the underbelly of things that were that
were going on from being involved so
much on the criminal justice side I
board ER I knew about Arizona's issues
with the cartels that were using the
Arizona border up I was very
knowledgeable about Indian country as
the US Attorney I was the prosecutor in
Indian country and those are typically
rural high poverty areas so I had that
experience behind me and that was
already shaping my vision second Arizona
State University had an institute called
the Morrison Public Policy Institute and
they put out early in that election a
very influential document called five
shoes ready to drop on Arizona and they
had looked at the whole kind of tapestry
of issues and had identified early
childhood k12 immigration etc that was
that paper was actually used by both
sides in the debates so that it was
interesting well a lot of University
papers don't actually get into the
public spheres that actively but that
helped me set the agenda and the third
thing that helped me set the agenda was
looking at time and what I thought I
could push through that the public would
be with me on so we focused on a couple
of key things one thing we focused on
was having all-day kindergarten
available for every child in Arizona
because the the data was persuasive that
that really helped close the gap so that
first graders started more equivalently
than they would otherwise
and then that therefore first grade was
more valuable third grades more valuable
from first redzone and that was a huge
fight the legislature didn't want to
fund it they want a fun half-day
kindergarten much less full-day is that
always around just the financial issues
or well that's how its talked about
I actually think sometimes the financial
issues cover for a lot of other things
that are going on but it was it's a big
dollar issue and a big dollar issue for
a very young state like Arizona so but
we managed to get that through and that
was one higher education I knew that our
economy needed to grow from being a real
estate based land based economy we
needed to bring in things like some new
research like genomics that referenced
in the introduction and so that means
you've got to have universities and in
the western states the public
universities are the primary place
people go and and that meant more
funding for universities also a terrific
terrific fight but those were the the
kind of I kind of had a vision of how we
scoped the education system with an idea
to the economy that we would want to
sustain in decades to come so the if you
look back what was the achievement you
most remember and feel best about and
what was one you wished you did but
didn't happen you can't do it oh yeah
particularly when the headwinds are
against in the legislature and and one
of my roles quite frankly was being the
backstop because during my tenure I'm
not proud of this necessarily but it is
a fact I
vetoed more than 150 bills and they
never overrode a veto but but some of
the bills were just bad some of them
were sent to me on purpose because they
knew I was going to beat them but some
of them were just bad oh I vetoed the
first budget they sent me they waited
till the very end of the fiscal year
they were kind of calling my bluff and
because the budget they sent me had all
their stuff and none of my stuff that's
not fair as President Obama said at one
time I won the election and elections
have consequences so the clerk brought
the the budget document up to the 9th
floor where the governor's offices in
the Capitol Tower and I was getting
ready to veto it and we realized that
nobody could find the stamp the beat we
could find it well it turns out that
governor's take veto stamps with him
it's kind of souvenirs when they leave
them anyway so I had to send somebody up
to Staples to get a veto stamp
I said get a self-inking one cuz we're
gonna use it a lot I suspect but anyway
so there's send me this budget and I met
the clerk almost literally at the
elevator said don't leave we were ready
sent it back they sent me another one I
was able with that one with line-item
veto authority to make it much better
and we got through and every year we got
through on time with a balanced budget
but it was always that kind of
last-minute tussle to get it done
so maybe serving as the finger in the
dike was an important role that I played
I think that a lot of what we did with
early childhood education has had an
important role although once I left and
the government changed hands they
repealed all-day kindergarten
nonetheless the table was set and
now I see more and more going into early
ed in Arizona by the initiative process
which is a vote of the people as opposed
to the legislature and I feel good about
that and I feel good about how we were
able to grow higher ed while I was there
although again since I've gone it's been
under duress so those are things I feel
good about lots of things I I would have
worked on more I not done on the
education front i I think child welfare
was a big issue remains an issue the
article in New York Times today about
child welfare in Arizona and it's and we
had made a lot of progress I think there
was a lot of backtrack after I left but
the protection of children I believe is
a key role when the family is either not
present or is incapable of protecting a
child so I would have wanted to do more
in that arena and then finally we were
not able to really change the economics
of Arizona and the changing economic a
very tough and it's a very long-term
thing but it is still primarily an
economy based on land and real estate so
when the recession hit it hit that state
very very hard Betty Johnson do we want
to take some questions that people have
sent in
yes thanks love we have a question from
our in audience student here today and
first it says as a former governor of
Arizona you have a good gauge of the
political climate in which the state is
currently embedded how would you propose
pushing health to the forefront of the
state's needs given the diversity and
budget of the state
I think it's it's interesting that
health hasn't occupied a higher ranking
on on the agenda I think sometimes when
we segregate health from everything else
it it you lose that political connection
you need to have with people one thing I
would suggest is that we focus not only
on cures or research but how we deal
with the check the way the health
systems have to change with the now
aging of the baiji baby boomer
population people don't want to go into
nursing homes they don't even want to go
into assisted care facilities they want
to a lot of them want to have the option
the choice of staying in home well how
do you do that and get them adequate
care well that means you've got to have
a whole cadre of trained people who are
public health associates they may be
LPNs they may be RNs or other types of
nurses other kinds of health
professionals who are writing the
circuit going around how do you provide
transportation how do you make sure
people are eating and eating well how do
you make sure people don't get isolated
in their in their homes because that
lack of human contact has a real health
aspect to it I'm a governor play a lead
role in getting that done yes I think
the governor actually Canada first of
all governor can state the problem and
and hopefully in a way that resonates
with people and I think if you talk
about that you will find so many people
who are I don't know how old you are my
age you know who are dealing with
getting their children educated and so
forth and
dealing with an aging parent who may
want to move in with Anik we have a
course called the Sandwich Generation
yeah
sandwiches right so I think there are
ways to express this and then you need
your health professionals to help you
scope out well what what is a new way to
think of that healthcare delivery system
how do you do it how do you pay for it
what is the federal government's role
there so in terms of the question asked
I would say take a step back and and and
look at segments of the population that
you know are large and are gonna have a
whole confluence of issues betting one
more in there one more question in this
area coming from our online audience
what did your perspective as governor
bring to your role at Homeland Security
perfect very good a lot in fact I think
I mean that was one of the reasons the
president asked me to do the job because
in homeland security you have to know
the public safety community you have to
know and deal with natural disasters you
know FEMA is part of the department of
homeland security very important part of
homeland security you have to have
experience dealing and issues like
public health we were talking about the
US response to the h1n1 epidemic
happened very early in President Obama's
term before we had a secretary of health
and before we had a director of CDC so
and in terms of the of the huge range of
missions that the Department of Homeland
Security has there's a big part of it
that relates
right to dealing with governors and
mayors and people on the ground in the
United States so there was a lot all of
that experience I took with me to
Washington so the for those who can go
online they are the largest number of
agencies many of them to summon for
distance are not completely related and
how you get that culture to work
together how do you make an apartment
where the Coast Guard and FEMA and
immigration groups work together in some
coherent way for that and then you are
laid on with the president who somehow
expects if he or she picks up the phone
and there's some problem there is a
response how do you go about thinking
about thatting Homeland Security formed
after the attack of 9/11 23 separate
agencies all from different legacy
departments etc merged together some new
ones created you add to the mix
responsibilities for terrorism
counterterrorism responsibilities for
immigration both that you know the legal
flow of people to and from the United
States as well as immigration
enforcement natural disasters FEMA
responsible for security the coasts of
the United States that's the Coast Guard
cybersecurity of the United States
within the jurisdiction where public
health is concerned there's actually a
Office of Health Affairs within the
department
it has statutory jurisdiction in certain
types of epidemic or pandemic situations
so you have that you have your own
intelligence analysis operation you work
with the CIA you work with the FBI you
work with all the other Intel apparatus
of the United States but you have your
own as well you have all of that you
have about a quarter of a million people
who report to you you have the third
largest Department budget-wise in the
United States government and personnel
wise next in defense and Veterans
Administration you have a hundred and
five Committees of the Congress who
exercise jurisdiction and you have no
headquarters building by the way you
office out of an old Navy Depot up by
the National Cathedral in in DC so it's
a really easy job
no challenges whatsoever I would say
many if not most people who are really
familiar with the federal government we
would name the department homeland
security is is one of the two or three
toughest jobs in in the government and
because you are in the barrel online all
the time every day regardless so one of
the the first things I had to do was
learn about the department and my
predecessor Mike Chertoff was very good
he had a transition team no Democrat had
led the department I was the only I was
only the third secretary I was still
serving as the governor of Arizona I
couldn't be sitting in Washington DC
transitioning so he sent teams out to
Phoenix to start getting me briefed
between the election and the
inauguration of course they had to leave
DC which was freezing and come to
Phoenix where it was in the 70s so I
think they were okay with that but I
remember coming out of my office door
and seeing some this guy walking down my
hallway with a dolly filled with these
huge binders literally from top to
bottom two of them that was my initial
round of briefing materials so I knew I
had a challenge ahead of me here's what
I did first thing I did and he's one of
the persons that it is governor one of
the first things I think anyone
parachuting into a large department or
agency needs to do
I dug into the budget and I had him
walked me through you know what was
mandatory what was discretionary which
funds went where why was this this way
this way why wasn't this here etc and
you know that makes for a pretty dry
reading but it's absolutely essential if
you're going to manage a government
department you need to know your budget
you need to know the acronyms sounds
funny but in government people speak in
acronyms and I finally asked for a
glossary from DHS because I couldn't
understand the memos and I got 94
single-spaced pages
acronyms for the department homeland
security I think there's an app for it
now actually and you begin to become
familiar with who's at the department
and just as you do as a governor
understanding who needs to be in your
key office team what are some of the key
spots within the department figuring
that out for DHS are they different than
when you were governor I mean different
types of people different or it's the
same thing a strong chief of staff yeah
I used a strong chief of staff model but
different from governor there's actually
a deputy secretary at DHS I didn't have
a lieutenant governor in Arizona we
don't have that organizational style
structure and so and she's also she was
also a presidential appointment Senate
confirmed and the heads of the major
operating components were all
presidential appointments Senate
confirmed so they were coming in taking
over large departments themselves with
their own basis of authority and backing
from the White House they had been you
know I didn't know them by and large so
we became very familiar with each other
very quickly but it made picking that
inner office team all the more important
yeah so I brought with me some people
from Arizona
you know everybody's excited the Obama
administration it was great excitement
let's let's go to Washington and so we
brought a number with us and then you
know learn in overtime you know how to
how to put the operational components
together in a in a logical way so the
major heads of the divisions are not
actually selected by the secretaries
they're not no so but that turned out to
be a problem not really because as as we
went forward the administration was very
careful to make sure that I at least had
the opportunity to interview
somebody and talk with them but
nonetheless you don't really get to know
people until you're working with them
day to day so we had to learn how to do
that and then the department was spread
out all over Washington DC as I
mentioned there was it's not like the
Pentagon where you go to one place I
mean it was literally you know in I
think it was I think we had something
like 64 different buildings and offices
within within the district and then into
Maryland and Northern Virginia so how do
you arrange that how do you stay in
touch how do you manage what happens
when you have something occurring where
you need the participation of the TSA
the CBP FEMA the Coast Guard the Office
of Health Affairs the office of Intel
analysis the national protection
Directorate and maybe they even a Secret
Service so how do you do that how do you
you do it a couple things one is I
established regular bi-weekly every
other week meetings with the major
component heads so they were talking
with each other at least in that context
secondly we developed a system of
conference calls and a whole protocol
for how we stayed in touch during a
crisis if people needed to be at their
places monitoring what they did but
needed to be in touch with each other
and that system we evolved it during my
secretary ship but it became very
effective thirdly always looking for
problems to be addressed in a multi
within the department interdepartmental
way part of this is just creating a
culture of working together not not
always on your own and realizing the
capabilities of other aspects of the
department with whom you may have been a
competitor before DHS
created so it's just a couple more and
then we'll go to the questions and as
governor in some senses you were your
own boss now you're heading this huge
agency but it relates to the White House
in different ways is that a problem when
you take over being a cabinet secretary
with relationships to the White House
kind of idyllic well it's a change it's
a real transition and you know as a
governor you you're kind of like the
president knows your state yes right and
you get used to that it's kind of cool
when you join the cabinet you're taking
an oath to support the president and
enforce the laws United States the
Constitution of the United States but
you are part of a team of an
administration led by the President of
the United States and that was an
adjustment I adjusted pretty quickly I
think
at the staff level in some respects it
was a more difficult adjustment and you
know learning who when the White House
called look there are a lot of people
who work at the White House from the
president down to you know a 19-year old
intern a 19-year old intern may call
saying I'm from the White House doesn't
mean I have to answer the phone so you
know just just kind of getting used to
okay who are the key players in the
White House and when the White House
calls where does where should that
appropriately be referred to within the
department Betty yes this question comes
from our online audience you are no
stranger to controversial and polarizing
policy issues when you think about
issues however you faced at the Homeland
Security are there lessons particularly
for aspiring leaders current leaders or
even the US Congress yes last was a
tough one yes
the most difficult issue I confronted at
the department was immigration
it was difficult personally I mean I've
lived almost my whole life in a boor I
grew up in New Mexico I'd spent most of
my adult life in Arizona
and I'm a very I think a few about the
back and forth of immigration visa via
the United States Mexico and and indeed
Central America and you know the notion
that there's real commerce there's a lot
of things that go on at borders and
borders need to be effective borders
they're not walls and so I had that
vision for the border the immigration
laws of the United States sorely need
comprehensive reform these they just do
not match reality in some respects but
yet my job and and the job of ice was to
enforce those laws so how do you do that
in the best way possible while you're
knocking your head over on the hill
trying to get immigration reform through
we got it through the Senate the house
would never hear so frustrating and I
think one of the issues that as a nation
we need to address if we're really going
to thrive as much as we can in the years
to come so I was charged with enforcing
the immigration laws even as I was
trying to reform the immigration laws
that is a very difficult position to be
in and I I've lost a lot of sleep over
that over over over over the years we
set priorities about which cases should
go first
translating those priorities and to and
agents actions in the field a very very
difficult thing to do we did invent daca
deferred Act
for childhood arrivals but we did that
only after it was so clear that even the
DREAM Act was not going to pass the
Congress and how unfair wasn't for the
United States to punish young people who
and we're not responsible for being in
the United States without documentation
but they were here they had grown up
here they were ready to go to college
here and so we invented daca which now I
think the current number of students who
are daca enrolled is around 700,000 but
we knew that would face opposition in
the Congress and the courts etc but it's
there it exists students are enrolled in
it I remember very distinctly being at a
hearing at the Senate Judiciary
Committee and I'm the only witness so
you're in this table and the Senators up
there and the audience is behind you and
the senator from Alabama is you know
going at me saying you're not enforcing
the immigration laws you know bad
secretary bad secretary and in the back
I have a bunch of people with signs
saying you know basically you're over
enforcing the immigration laws bad
secretary bad secretary and and I really
felt them physically how much in the
middle on immigration being the DHS
secretary is the I'm afraid that the
audience in California will say that he
has an East Coast prejudice he hasn't
asked about the University of California
so in the time remaining I think we
asked the switch to your third role as
president of RC California that must be
a nice quiet job in comparison security
well let me give you a sense of scale so
the our budget is right around 26
billion dollars a year right when I left
Arizona the budget for the entire state
was nine point eight billion the budget
for the state now is like nine
1 billion if if the University of
California were a state it would
probably be number 12 to 15 right around
in the air in terms of the size of the
budget so let's not pretend that when we
put university of in front of the name
that it is this mild mannered nice soft
academic environment where I can think
great thoughts and you know whatever
that how you think of it ya know and and
in some respects it's you know I took it
on because I love the mission yeah I'm
motivated by public service and I think
education is just the way you do so many
things and I think public higher
education is the one proven tactic we've
had in this country for social mobility
so so the mission I was excited about
the mission I had told the president
after his reelect that another year or
so is at DHS but as you can tell from
our discussion it's a it it's a
physically exhausting job among other
things and I really thought it would
benefit by some fresh eyes and I thought
boy
what did I enjoy doing in Arizona I
loved the education and I love the
higher education stuff so I thought well
that would be kind of nice you know be
President University neat and I wanted
to move back west I'm a westerner and
there are differences
no comment I mean I like you know except
for the Yankees anyway we'll talk about
that later anyway and then I got a call
from a headhunter
you know they well the University of
California is looking for a president
would I be interested and I said would
they be interested because I'm not gonna
say I'm interested till they say they're
interested it's like high school so they
call back said yeah they're very
interested and I went through the
process and was fortunate to be selected
and we have lots of challenges why in
part because public higher education in
this country is in an enormous period of
evolution where the public is unwilling
to invest at as much as it did
previously we don't understand I don't
understand why that is but I think it's
a fact but at the same time the need to
provide a quality higher education
particularly one with access to learning
about the research process is absolutely
key to the United States ability to
thrive in this century so dealing with
that dealing with the politics of can
you ever raise tuition even if you
promise that over half the California
students don't won't pay the tuition can
you ever raise it how many out of state
students can you admit to help help you
financially among other things and and
then you know the different
constituencies of a university in
particularly the faculty and the
students and
and relations with with those across a
broad broad spectrum so it's a it is a
rewarding post but perhaps my most in a
way immense it's it's hard to beat DHS
for complexity I was gonna say it's I
don't think you can do that but I can
programs in schools every experience
that I have had in the way in the way of
trying to lead and persuade and bring
people along and have a broader vision
and a longer-term view all of those
things are being brought to bear and
it's funny I talk to people in DC and
they they kind of think I'm relaxing and
it looks so much more relaxing than
thinking really I must have looked
terrible when I was really really
pounded it out out there the is your
strategy about trying to move ahead
differently than in the other role she
took on is having students and faculty
make you think very differently about
how you bring about change or is it
similar it's different and learning
about for example in a research
university
the notion or the principles of shared
governance with the faculty the faculty
are the ones who control the curricular
process what goes into a curriculum what
constitutes a degree the tenure process
and I'm very respectful of the
principles of shared governance but I
had to learn about it I mean it's not
something that I was familiar with and
rely in the student students of our
broad spectrum from you know grad
students of the highest caliber doing
the most amazing research not just in
the STEM disciplines but in the
humanities and the arts and the
qualitative Social Sciences and public
policies down to or across to I should
say across to students who have a
particular area of interest in one
political issue and they want to push
that agenda forward and so you have to
deal with that and and then learning
about California politics in California
politic California you know it's 38
million people it could be its own
country and and so getting a crash
course in the politics out there so all
of that come into play coming to bear
the with the last few minutes sitting in
our audience people who would like it
some time to be sitting right where you
are is there advice that we can give to
the next generation things they can do
things that they think about in terms of
the choices and essentially mission that
you had that you would give them I think
look first of all I find public service
a passion you know I just believe that
what whatever talents I have that's how
I want to spend it to spend them and
that helps you get through the tough
times because in public service there
are tough times if you're gonna be in a
leadership role and you and you go
through I call it earning your calluses
and some some say getting a thick skin
but even the thickest of skins can get
pierced at times so but so you have to
have something that causes you to keep
the engine running and I have it I don't
know how I got it I have it
and I love what I do and I and I love
being able to meet somebody in an
airport who comes up and says you know
you helped me do this you helped my
family do that etc s tremendously
rewarding you need to have a way to keep
that in mind you need to create a
broader vision if all you do is deal
with the crisis du jour you can never
actually move a large institution
forward and large institutions by and
large take time to move you don't do it
in nine months for a year 18 months you
try to do it within two or three but it
takes time and you've got to have the
patience and the persistence to stay to
say it and have the courage of your
convictions about what you're doing and
then lastly I would say leaders are
human beings too
and you have to figure out how you want
to balance the rest of your life so that
from a mental standpoint you can stay in
balance for me you know I like going to
live music I like going to the movies
you know I like going hiking you know
that kind of thing
and then you have to be disciplined
enough to tell your staff that that's
your time and that they can't schedule
over your time which they will by the
way because as I said if you're going to
persist over the long haul you've got to
take care of yourself as a human being -
let me close thank very very much for
the credible social
you